- [Instructor] A catalyst
speeds up a reaction
by lowering the activation energy.
And there are many types of catalysts.
And first we're going to look at enzymes
which are biological catalysts.
Let's say that this represents our enzyme,
and the place where the reaction occurs
is called the active site of the enzyme.
So right in here, let's say
this is our active site.
And then the substance that
reacts at the active site
is called the substrate.
So this little picture here
with two triangles together,
that's the substrate for our reaction.
In the next step,
the substrate binds to the
enzyme at the active site.
And when the substrate binds,
the substrate can produce
changes in the shape
of the active site, that
allow for better binding.
So on the left here, we
can see how the shape
of the active site changes slightly
when the substrate binds to it.
This formation of the
enzyme substrate complex
is called the induced fit model.
The substrate interacts with the enzyme
through non-covalent
interactions in the active site.
So things like hydrogen bonding
or dipole-dipole interactions.
Perhaps some of these
non-covalent interactions
cause a shift in electron density
which make it easier
to reach the transition
state for the reaction.
Therefore lowering the activation energy
and speeding up the overall reaction.
Next let's say the bond between
the two triangles breaks
and we get our two products here.
So two individual triangles.
And the enzyme active site
goes back to the original shape
and it's ready to
catalyze another reaction.
Next, let's talk about
a homogeneous catalyst,
which is a catalyst that's present
in the same phase as the
reactants in a reaction mixture.
So let's look at the hydrolysis of sucrose
to turn into glucose and fructose.
This reaction can be catalyzed
by the hydronium ion H30+.
And since sucrose, our reactant
is an aqueous solution,
and so as the hydronium ion,
we can say that the hydronium
ion is a homogeneous catalyst.
And it's a source of protons
to catalyze this hydrolysis reaction.
This is a drawing of the sucrose molecule,
which is a disaccharide
composed of two monosaccharides.
Glucose is over here on the left
and fructose is over here on the right.
And these two monosaccharides are joined
by an ether linkage.
So we can see, we can see this,
this connection here, alright?
This oxygen in between
our two monosaccharides
isn't ether linkage.
And ethers are fairly nonreactive.
Since ethers are generally unreactive,
the hydrolysis of sucrose
is a pretty slow reaction.
And to speed it up, we need
to add an acid catalyst.
So if we add an acid catalyst
and we have hydronium
ions in aqueous solution,
a lone pair of electrons
on the oxygen on the ether,
will take this proton
and these electrons move in to form water.
Protonation of the oxygen,
gives the oxygen a plus one formal charge.
And allows an acid catalyzed
mechanism to proceed.
And there are more steps to the mechanism
but ultimately sucrose is
broken down to form glucose
and fructose in this acid
catalyzed hydrolysis of sucrose.
Honey bees actually have the
enzyme to convert sucrose
which is table sugar,
into glucose and fructose.
And since fructose is
sweeter than sucrose,
honey is sweeter than table sugar.
A heterogeneous catalyst is
a catalyst that's present
in a different phase
from the reactants in a reaction mixture.
As an example, let's look
at a hydrogenation reaction.
And this reaction ethene
reacts with hydrogen
on a surface of platinum to form ethane.
Now, since the platinum
is in the solid form
and our reactants are
in the gaseous state,
the platinum is an example
of a heterogeneous catalyst.
So here in our picture, we have
our piece of platinum metal
and both the ethene molecule
and hydrogen are adsorbed
to the surface of the platinum metal.
Next the bond between the
two hydrogen atoms breaks
and we get the two individual
hydrogen atoms bonded
to the surface of the platinum metal.
Eventually these two hydrogens
add across the double bond of ethene
and form the ethane molecules C2H6.
So the hydrogenation of
ethene to form ethane
is catalyzed by the presence
of the platinum metal.